what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest in the one piece
story this chapter we learned more about
shimotsuki ushimaru the great swordsman
of wano who both looks and fights like
zoro i gotta say wano is really turning
out to be zoro's arc and since i love
zorro i'm loving it as well and we got
much more happening too so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these one piece reviews i want to
keep them coming channel the power king
with it and smash that like button with
no mercy smashing the like button is
pirate king energy and not doing it is
orochi energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my big and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos of all the yonko warlords
admirals mythical zone users and much
more linked to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all on
this week's cover of shonen jump one
piece is dominating it in order to
celebrate 100 volumes crazy to think how
far one piece has come and how good it
is after so long there is an amazing
two-page cover spread that includes our
straw hats along with other choice
characters like kid inel moria and i
love to see boa there as well great
image and luffy and zorro really look
cool next to each other here still
waiting on moria to make an appearance
on wano in order to help carry out his
long planned revenge against kaido the
chapter itself is called nobody
important which is just like the most
ironic title ever and i love it but more
on that when it's mentioned in context
in the actual chapter the chapter starts
with usop giving us quite the
performance as he excels at doing there
is conker's haki affecting a lot of men
but notably not our boy usop usab takes
advantage by saying that it can't be
helped it's natural for men with weak
resolve to crumble before him it would
go more with usob's character to be
playing off another person's conqueror's
hockey than his own but who knows
perhaps usop will actually turn out to
have conquerors haki his dad is
definitely a legendary pirate so it
isn't out of the realm of possibility
perhaps one day usop will make
everything he pretends to be a reality
and that's his character arc for now
though he keeps fibbing saying he took
down the two flying six members and he
calls himself usohachi the beast hunter
it's hilarious how he's riding on top of
a crocodile smile and how people respond
to this they freak out and usopp offers
them a chance to join him before he
wipes them out speed is definitely of
the opinion that the conker's hockey
present is a mere echo of big moms who's
fighting on this floor the straw hats
start communicating with each other via
snails they are wondering what happened
to luffy but can get a hold of him the
last update they got was when momo
assured him that luffy was alright i
love frankie's line that no news is
probably good news he's right as we know
but i also love the optimism while nami
is not having that answer at all frankie
lets them know to come down because a
bunch of enemies are trying to get to
the live floor and they gotta defend it
so that zoro and sanji can take the
all-stars on in peace you have the
tendencies of worst generation captains
rubbing off on their cruise here as
frankie lets them know what they gotta
do and law's men insist that frankie
can't give them orders because they're
in an equal alliance as if that's at all
relevant in the midst of battle it is
significant though that not only does
luffy give the orders his crew does too
solidifying how they're destined to
become the pirate king crew in the
meantime on the third floor there are
out of control flames so everyone is
trying to escape to the live floor and
we see brooke carrying robin to safety
and now that we know black maria's
bounty is 480 million berries i have
even more appreciation for how
impressive robin's victory was we even
get to see jimbei whom brook calls to
ask for assistance of course jinbe isn't
satisfied with just helping by taking
out who's who and he's already wondering
what kaido is up to in this chapter we
are getting a lot of short moments about
the updated positions for our characters
kawamatsu is also shown as the samurai
standard ground to keep the enemy from
interfering with zorro and sanji's
battles we then pop back to the fight
against kaido and yamato yamato is
clearly on the defensive while kaido
looks like he's enjoying himself
launching attacks like thunderous arrow
for yamatota block yamato is out of
breath and finally says kaido is trying
to kill her yamato saying this means
that although kaido fought with her in
the past he was always holding back but
now is different and that makes sense
because there's a big war going on it's
not just a random fight in the middle of
an uneventful day yamato can't really be
surprised by kaido's actions here
especially since she's the one who
insists on them fighting kaido obviously
seems like a horrible father for what
we've heard so far but as a yonko he's
been very lenient to yamato as someone
who's repeatedly challenged him over and
over again for about two decades he says
as much saying that this isn't a family
squabble anymore yamato should have been
prepared for war and carrying odin's
name comes with a heavy burden of course
kaido is not playing around anymore and
a lot of what he's saying makes sense in
the middle of a war you can't go around
calling yourself by the name of a
yonko's enemy and challenge him and
expect him to go easy on you i'm playing
devil's advocate here but we gotta
remember that kaido isn't just yamato's
dad he's also the leader in one of the
biggest wars we've seen in one piece so
far and will understandably act
accordingly yamato barks back what's
wrong with admiring odin since she was
captivated by him and that's when we get
to the part that's the most interesting
to me in this chapter we get a flashback
where the only princess aka yamato has
been throwing a non-stop tantrum for a
week saying she's odin there must be
some conflicting feelings going on for
kaido as a hurt kid yamato asks for her
daddy to let her out of the chains while
also insisting that she's kazuki odin as
kaido finds out she knocked out the
people around her and he deduces that
she too has conquered his hockey it's
really no surprise that kaido was
remarking that there's so many people
conquer his hockey when luffy kid and
zoro came along yamato is hungry and
begs for food while kaido is thinking
that if she insists on calling herself
odin it would be better if she died and
this shocks her at this point kaido
might have thought it was a phase but as
we know in the present it's been like
two decades of this already and so it's
not surprising that in the middle of a
war he's not holding back anymore but
back to the flashback he puts yamato in
a cave and gives her a month to cool off
and consider things he puts her in a
cave with so-called wild samurai
probably hoping that they'll antagonize
her and help her get over calling
herself to samurai odin she cries as
kaido leaves her in the cave kaido also
says that his words apply to the samurai
present saying he would like to have
wano's great swordsman serving under him
as well it's all a matter of one's will
and despite how strong kaido is
physically it infuriates him that they
are just wills like his own daughters
that he cannot conquer kaido says that
it's been days since the samurai have
eaten so he'll leave them a portion of
food expecting them to fight over like
dogs he even gives them samurai swords
to use yamato cries out as now the
samurai can easily slice her up she
fears they'll resent her for being
kaido's child and as she says she'll be
killed kaido turns around and coldly
mocks her saying but i thought you were
odin for kaido she cannot be his
daughter and odin but for her she is
both odin and kaido is also her father
the two aren't mutually exclusive back
to the food and yamato is crying and
worried that the samurai are going to
kill her first before they start
fighting each other but to her surprise
the kyoshiro looking one gives the food
to her saying please eat and adding that
samurai do not get hungry i absolutely
love the stoic code of the samurai from
wano rather than giving a reason to
yamato to stop acting like a samurai
their actions probably only solidify her
resolve and she cries as she eats and
thinks samurai are amazing because they
never get hungry rather than knowing
they're just well disciplined even
though they are feeling the pain like
anyone else would then the one who looks
like zorro and is most likely ushimaru
shimotsuki zoro's dad or at least
relative but probably that smiles with
his face tilted upwards just like zoro
would do and says and i quote eat up you
were born into quite the family weren't
you she thanks to samurai saying she
will remember this bull for the rest of
her life yamato asks if she can become a
samurai and ushimaru cuts her chains off
and he comments that she wants to be
odin right saying that that man
captivated all of them again you have
his eye being covered partially by the
bandage except when he used the blade to
cut the chains ryuma was one-eyed now
zorro is one-eyed that is definitely not
a coincidence and there has to be some
power associated with the closed eye
among these shimotsuki anyways yamato
asks ushimaru if he was friends with
odin and who the samurai are but
ushimaru replies how is a disgrace
samurai meant to introduce himself i'm
nobody important there's such a nothing
happened vibe to that statement and this
moment along with the samurai don't get
hungry moment gave me chills of
awesomeness partly because of how epic
it was but also partly because of how
uncanny the similarities with zoro are
it completely makes sense that such a
cool character would come from such a
cool samurai and we all know at this
point that zoro has to have his origins
from moano even before all these wanna
reveals oda said that zoro would be
japanese in the real world and obviously
wano is the japan of one piece the
internet's been going crazy over zorro's
probable father reveal since last
chapter and i'm so glad this chapter
followed up by actually giving us
significantly more to work with
including getting to actually see the
character rather than just having people
describe him as being similar to zorro
in appearance and sword fighting style
eventually yamato whips out odin's
logbook asking if the samurai can help
her read it because it has lots of big
words and they go crazy over the fact
that she has odin's navigation log
although interestingly enough ushimaru
isn't shown losing his stoic expression
very zoro like indeed everything goes
counter to kaido's plan as even the hole
in the ceiling that's supposed to be how
they scream that they give up is used as
a light to read the book it's like
everything kaido tried to do to get
yamato to change her mind only served to
get her more committed to being odin and
being a samurai after 10 days the
samurai started wondering if kaido would
really leave his child to die remarking
that if this keeps up she's not going to
see the battle that odin predicted in 20
years but she's sure that when the time
comes she'll fight for wano which is
what's happening right now in the
present and then she'll go to sea and
get much much stronger this is cool for
multiple reasons one it strongly lends
credence to yamato a mythical zone user
joining the straw hats as many of us
hope she will two the story probably can
be close to over if yamato and by
extension the rest of the straw hats
will keep getting much much stronger
after the battle of wano i absolutely
love to see it the samurai then decide
that they'll contribute to the future by
saving her since 20 years is too long
for their generation to wait we even see
ushimaru carrying two swords rather than
just one another not to zorro although
the third sword isn't there and correct
me if i'm wrong but we saw that ryuma
used one sword ushimaru here added one
so he has two and zoro added the third
one so you get a really cool progression
here and you know what they say about
the third one being the charm anyways
ushimaru breaks through the giant
boulder the samurai agree that they
can't sit there and starve like stray
dogs and they were never gonna yield so
may as well go down fighting now this
gives zorro an added significance here
since he might be in a way avenging his
father and again i think it would be so
cool if zoro got the cut down kaido in
his dragon form because of how ryuma
slayed a dragon too but we'll see right
now i'm still glad that he's fighting
king and we'll see if luffy ends up
needing a helping hand against kaido
after king is finished maybe kaido tries
to escape in his dragon form having lost
to luffy and zorro cuts him then to keep
him from escaping obviously that doesn't
seem too likely now since kaido is the
strongest creature and i'm getting ahead
of myself but i'm just trying to tie the
history together with the present to
create a kind of prophecy whatever
happens i'm loving the zorro attention
back to the fight and yamato says what
right did kaido have to steal her
freedom and wano's freedom while kaido
the more mature one at 59 years old says
there are no easy answers in this world
adding that she's an immature brat we
see a clash of black lightning between
two conquerors hockey users and two
mythical zone users and full props to
yamato for doing so well for so long i
don't think anyone expects her to win
but she's been amazing thus far and
definitely played a very important role
in delaying kaido up until now luffy and
momo should be there any second at this
point so again full props to her and
that is it for another epic chapter of
one piece i absolutely loved it as
always let me know what your favorite
part was and what you look forward to
seeing the most in the next chapter who
was your mvp for me it was between
ushimaru and yamato ushimaru didn't do
much but his presence was amazing and
what he did do stole the show on the
other hand yamato from a very young age
maintained her will and refused to
submit the kaido and finally did exactly
what she'd planned to do for two decades
and is now doing better than we could
have expected her to do against kaido
holding him up and doing an invaluable
service for wano and the straw hats
absolutely legendary both of them if you
did enjoy this review and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the pirate king within and smash that
like button with no mercy smashing the
like button is pyroking energy and not
doing so is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my big and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords admirals mythical zone
users and much more link to that is in
the description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord wigo
himself alpha sigma and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans ingrata but they have the al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike corey mcgowan dylan isadore spidey
life tennelle tungsten tarkis big
buddhist cody hebert and monkey d quilly
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
angel cruz brethuen de aura very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks joanne garcia
ted no ted batboy games and soul ride
slice and dice thank you all so much if
you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
animeoutroar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get a name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patronly discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you are interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer and whichever way
to support us you will get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you